what if we found a way to drain all the
Earth's oceans through some mysterious
portal at the bottom of the Mariana
Trench how long would it take years
centuries millennia would there be any
life left on earth when the pumping was
over what if it happened overnight this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we drained all the world's oceans
ocean water makes up 70% of the Earth's
surface how much liquid is that exactly
well if you could put all that water
into Olympic sized swimming pools you'd
need this many of them even if we opened
a portal about the size of a basketball
court it would take us hundreds of
thousands of years to drain the oceans
they hold over a billion cubic
kilometers of water but what if we had a
pump powerful enough to drain all the
oceans in a minute what would happen
then sure enough swimmers sailors cruise
passengers everyone out on the ocean
would feel the effects quickly within a
second boaters and swimmers in shallow
water would crash onto the bottom they'd
get away with a few broken bones deep
ocean ships wouldn't be so lucky a
titanic sized liner would hit the bottom
in 30 seconds and smash into tiny pieces
the same thing would happen to just
about every large ship on the ocean
within the first minute what about all
the sea creatures you already know the
answer it would literally be raining
fish since all the whales dolphins and
other big aquatic animals curiously
exploring the surface would be falling
to the ocean floor as for those already
near the bottom they'd be lucky not to
get sucked down the drain along with the
water but what comes next is where the
real trouble begins our oceans have two
life supporting roles first they
regulate global temperatures by
absorbing energy from the Sun they push
warm tropical waters north and south and
circulate cold waters back to the
equator this way no place on earth gets
too hot or way too cold
global climate control second oceans
feed the water cycle evaporating into
the clouds and raining back to earth the
moment the oceans disappeared
the earth would turn into a vast desert
go ahead and throw away your umbrella
since it's never gonna rain again
wait what about all the lakes and rivers
can we get by with those
well without oceans the world loses 97%
of its water the small amount of liquid
left would not be enough to sustain the
water cycle the pools of drinkable water
would evaporate pretty fast in a matter
of days people and most animals would
die from dehydration plants would have a
few weeks before they started decaying
in the dry air within a few months
forests would begin massive die-offs and
all this dry dead vegetation would
eventually ignite in a matter of years
most of the world's forests would be
burned down as these huge bonfires
sparked all across the planet the
atmosphere would become less and less
oxygenated if there were still humans at
this time the unbreathable air and
scorching temperature would wipe us out
for good all in all the earth would end
up just like Venus cooked so why not
take a few days off and enjoy a little
seaside vacation while you can isn't it
time to explore how your what-if
scenario would turn out
you